let's bring in Congressman Tony Gonzalez
he's a member of the House Homeland
Security committee Congressman good
morning to you good morning
good morning thank you for having me
listen uh we want to share with you we
know you've got some video but we want
to share with you something that uh our
correspondent Bill malusian tweeted out
yesterday uh first up new security video
from a contact in Eagle Pass Texas shows
a large group of migrants Crossing
illegally onto private property this
morning Crossings have been down big in
Texas the last few days but are expected
to rise again as cartels and Smugglers
figure out the post title 42 border and
then it continues I asked the Texas
National Guard if this is one of their
soldiers who opens the gate for the
group of migrants they tell me she is
not a Texas Soldier and is not a Texas
Army National Guard I'm told she is a
title 10 soldier from the Missouri Army
National Guard under orders from the
federal government and working with
border patrol so a lot of people
Congressman were saying who exactly is
opening that gate for that large mass of
migrants and as it turns out it's
somebody who's doing it at the direction
of the federal government
yeah that's the frustration we have
along the border and and I think Fox and
I think Bill malusian and Griff Jenkins
for for giving us the the images because
the images tell the story when you see a
Guardsman open up a gate and let people
in the borders not secure and that's the
frustration we have is you know imagine
in Texas we have grocery stores called
HEB imagine you go to the grocery store
you pick a number to wait for the deli
your number's four but yet these people
are cutting in line and so what about
the people that are doing it the right
way what about the Americans that came
over the right way that live along along
the border following the rules and yet
you have people that just break the
rules every single day it's wrong on all
ends and we're we're very frustrated but
we're also we can't stop fighting we
can't say it's okay that's what I'm
hearing too everyone's going it's not
that bad you look at those images that's
what not that bad looks like you got ten
thousand every day last Monday same
number on Tuesday same number on
Wednesday and we continuously hear that
those numbers are high and that many of
the shelters down there in South Texas
are over flowing and there's not enough
room that's why they're having to ship
them to other cities what are you seeing
I know you have this video from El Paso
yeah no I I traveled to El Paso on
Friday to the central processing center
and I've been there many times and I'd
never seen it in this porous condition
that place can house a thousand people
it was housing three thousand and in one
cell in particular that could house a
little over 100 people or over 700 they
were all single adult males I I spoke
with one individual he told me he had
been in there for 18 days legally you
can't hold someone for more than 72
hours what I wanted to show is if you
look at those images you should be
feared it you should be your your blood
should boil and you should get upset
with what is happening also last week no
one seems to talk about it but there was
a migrant child that died in HHS custody
so these are these are things that can't
be normal I've been pushing back against
that a lot of us continue to push back
here in the house but we can't stop
until we've pushed Biden to make the
changes that need to happen which is
essentially enforce the laws that are on
are that are already on the books that's
what we're asking for so should single
males be able to get in I mean what is
their explanation for getting in I don't
like my government what are they saying
to be able to get to the point where
they're in America
yeah it's it's the cartel controls
everything as you'll know what has to
happen is we have to Surge immigration
judges to the border and these folks
need to get their cases heard in days
and if they don't qualify for Asylum we
send them back to their country of
origin you do that for a month and this
goes away and then you send those
immigration judges to the cities that
have been hit the hardest that's how you
solve the crisis uh Congressman you're
doing the great work on this we
appreciate it don't stop thank you thank
you thank you I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian
Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley Earhart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis